talk to me about war how does bitcoin
essentially prevent war because i
believe that that's what you say right
historically governments or these states
would bump into each other they go to
war or is the most expensive thing you
can do they could only fund that warfare
from their own balance sheet so
typically two states go to war someone
gets in financial straits they cut a
deal they sign a treaty there's an
armistice whatever well when you install
a central bank all of a sudden that
balance sheet is now expanded to the
entire savings of civilization because
they can print money to keep paying for
for the war effort until they
hyperinflate the currency and collapse
they confiscate all the wealth in the
entire country versus just the state so
again this led to the overgrowth of the
state and therefore the overgrowth of
warfare basically by virtue of bitcoin
existing as an option states now have to
go back to the original means of funding
war which is explicit taxes like i'm
sending you a bill
or borrowing the land show